i think that people they should be
afraid of investing in crypto because i
feel like not enough people are afraid
to picture these people like in a
discord talking with people with like
[ __ ] monkey pictures and [ __ ] and
they're like nah dude this is definitely
gonna make you a bazillionaire and this
is some guy like just some pud on his
laptop who's like okay guys crypto isn't
real it's just zynga poker on steroids
how am i supposed to look my kid in the
eyes i lost all the zynga poker money he
loved zynga poker oh my god dude
honey what happened to all our zynga
poker money
what are we gonna eat today oh yeah yeah
could you buy like emotes and [ __ ] in
that game i can't remember
i don't know i never played it it's just
like i'm just picturing like you know he
loves to play with the
with the [ __ ] charlie chaplin
mustache and now we don't have any coins
to pay for it
have you played vr poker charlie no i
haven't played vr dude you've got to oh
that is that is right content for you
man i'm telling you it's so funny i'm
down it's [ __ ] awesome are you still
making music yeah we're working on some
new boner jams right now we're in the
lab cooking them up oh yeah do you
produce them no so i have no musical
gift at all i just come up with the with
the lyrics and the melody but my boy
troy he's the the man behind the music
he makes all the music and everything
makes it sound good i also can't sing at
all so he makes me sound good
it's a great partnership i just love how
you describe your work process for
everything yeah i don't even know how to
use a computer but yes there's like i go
on twitter and i you know find some [ __ ]
and i just talk and then uh yeah um i
actually film it like in a canon printer
camera i got an lg chocolate that yeah
yeah yeah
was that [ __ ] uh early like webcam
that went into like a
game boy advance or no it was just a
straight game boy yeah i saw it in a
museum literally yo i remember that oh
my god yeah i had that camera uh why why
did we show this every message after
this podcast episode gonna be like well
look it's it's you love that it's black
and white like how [ __ ] old are we
jesus christ you remember that silent
film game
on game boy you remember that motion
picture we saw that one time wait to get
the vhs
this is very quickly devolving into
three guys on the computer we gotta get
out of here i love it dude i'm having so
much fun yeah dude honestly charlie
thank you for doing this is like the
best episode we've had in a minute this
was a lot of fun guys thank you for
having me on wait wait wait you boys are
always welcome in the area oh thank you
man dude i have to ask this and we can
edit this out if you're not allowed to
leak it are you and ludwig gonna do the
the slap the slapbox uh i think so i
think he wants to make that happen i'm
not positive though i haven't heard back
in like a couple months are you
competing i would i would love to but
i'm paranoid like i don't want to find
out in front of a lot of people that i
don't have a chin because i have no clue
same i'm bro i've been saying this for
like like what a year now i just don't
feel comfortable slapping or fighting
anyone that's not a child because i
honestly feel like at any moment like
one stray hits just gonna send me to the
hospital like snap my [ __ ] neck i'd
only fight like ryan's toy reviews or
something and i know you said you're
saying you would be you would be
comfortable no dude that's not my bit i
think we all want to fight ryan's toys i
think we're all envious of how much
[ __ ]
scratch that kid is pulling in for doing
[ __ ] all dude but i just relate so hard
man yeah i would i would feel very
comfort like because i know i could beat
a kid without getting hit like that i
know i wouldn't get hit it'd be it'd be
so free but if i get hit i'm like i
could just go down and die yeah like i
could just like seize up or something
yeah that's the thing yeah we already
talked about this but like did you watch
crater clash no yeah yeah like when
graham steffen he got hit with that
first punch you could see it in his face
that it's like his whole perspective on
life changed charlie in that moment
didn't you commentate yeah yes i i had a
really good view of the creation yeah
yeah oh you caught oh you did yeah yeah
i was just kind of the color commentary
guy who didn't know too much about
boxing so i'd usually just say like holy
[ __ ] no that was the funniest part to me
just hearing you chime in and just go
yeah he yeah
he just [ __ ] got
blasted that that's my other fear with
boxing and like i feel
i feel like idubbbz trying to underscore
that it's very dangerous like doesn't
get enough credit there's so many
stories of boxers like taking like hits
in the ring and then continuing a fight
and then they just go into a coma hours
later and then just die oh my god
especially those back of the head hits
which were happening a lot of times a
lot there were some kangaroo punches and
like since it's the first time people
were getting hit they'd always like turn
around and get hit again bro
bro you might just die dude the amount
of like showing the rear skull i was
just screaming at my phone i'm like stop
it just take it on the face don't
[ __ ] do that yeah take it on the face
man so yeah i mean to answer your
question i would
i think i would with headgear but
wait as you do a slapping company oh no
no sorry sorry
the other part he was saying like actual
oh gotcha gotcha i don't want to like
kill it but he was like talking about
like actual combat and i i i think i
would do it with head gear i've like
like i've done like very light sparring
but yeah i don't know what it's like to
get a full on like [ __ ]
like
targeted
prepared punch you know what i mean
because even like a street fight even if
you like fight someone who's like strong
i feel like it's still not the same as
someone who's like punching a bag for a
year straight pretending it's your head
and then doing that to you yeah i
couldn't imagine it i've never been in a
situation where someone's actively going
to punch me and i know it's coming yeah
have either of you guys been in a fight
before i was like the smallest kid out
of my group in high school so i just
learned to be funny so no one would [ __ ]
with me yeah i always had to like play
[ __ ] off as the comedian like i watched
my friends fight all the time and they
never looked good have you been in a
street fight no i've only ever like
broken up a fight like once or twice and
that was just for the sake of me saying
like i was there to help like you know i
got involved hell yeah dude peak
narcissism right there i just didn't
want my friends to think
this guy was crazy i mean i was about to
beat his ass if i didn't get broken up
yo i'm breaking up this fight get a
picture of this on your game boy camera
real quick check me out i'm going to
pose in front of this right yeah
that would be the lamest way to get hit
if you were breaking up a fight and you
accidentally took one to the face or
something yeah then you could because
you couldn't say yes to at people asking
if you've been in a fight before yeah
cause you just caught a stray a hundred
yeah exactly it's sad damn yeah i mean
that definitely happens just breaking up
a fight and getting dropped yeah yeah
guys guys let's do it
that's so sad it's very dark dude
classic internet tale that's what that
is
well damn it um all right man thank you
again bro thanks for joining us dude
really appreciate it a lot of fun let's
do this again yeah yeah thanks for
having me on guys i really enjoyed it
feel free to hit me up whenever if
you're ever in the area or anything like
that if you ever want to do anything i'm
super down yes i want to go to tampa and
i want to let's do a go-kart race so
like some shitty go-kart tracks some
rental carts i think it i know really if
you guys like like dilapidated
like amusement park go-kart kind of [ __ ]
i know a really cool spot yeah we should
race we should make dick cars and we
should all race them oh let's go yeah
dick carter send us your dad's number
[Laughter]
no wait wait wait wait let's let's let's
say this publicly so then we can get
shamed into doing it i want to do a race
where it's like it's like wacky racers
like it's basically formula one for
shitty cars like how funny would it be
if there was like a dick car a mock
flintstones car
you know what i mean like like like like
really good soapbox racing yeah but like
it's just like it's all like people who
make [ __ ] and like how funny would that
be if like like the sidemen came but
they like were like two welded tandem
bikes you know yeah that's good and then
like you know if you're racing solo you
can have a little bit more juice and
then yeah yeah wacky right but it's also
battle bots
and try to kill each other hillary get
those whipper on it and [ __ ]
torpedoes oh charlie just killed the
sidemen holy [ __ ]